[Musique]
alors en direct de cap canaveral à
montréal c'est le lancement de la
nouvelle saison 2009 2020 de tantale
canada à ça ça c'est ça ce songe de
lancement aujourd'hui vous êtes en forme
wii terriblement au milieu de l'été
comme ça on a l'impression d'être dans
une fusée et vous vous avez l'air plus
haute que d'habitude mais je ne sais pas
j'ai décidé la stib debout plutôt
qu'assis parce que j'étais inconfortable
alors voilà j'ai un site pas trop bouger
car même bon mondes et martin avec merci
à jour un fantastique nous avoir les
jours vous avez l'habitude vous des
sièges qui sont dus au fait gérable et
l'autre l'a fait beaucoup de vélo pas
toute l'année normes
on va éviter de passer à des choses
exactes à bhl ce pas très poli pas très
agréable marie claude simard bonjour
bonjour on vous a vu il ya quelques
minutes en direct parce que vous faites
beaucoup de direct vous à la section
anglaise de radio canada et est en
national d'émissions qui s'appelle en
anglais vous on vous a servi de la
poutine
oui nous avons mangé de l'apu de scène
parce que la fin de semaine dernière à
warwick au québec on a brisé un record
mondial de la plus grosse poutine du
monde plus de 3000 kg poutine extra
tease
alors écoutez assez fantastique c'est un
beau menu sa démission pour l'été l'âge
aussi on a quelque chose d'un peu
spéciale à vous proposer aujourd'hui
avant deviner ans a reçu la démission
parce que vous connaissez rien comme
d'habitude on vous lance un défi à la
régie aussi les impliquer dans ce
lancement d'éditions premier défi de la
régie et moi je lis les mémos même quand
je suis en vacances du patron et il
envoyait dit voici une nouvelle page qui
offre nous balade au aux internautes
sont en ligne vous allez voir qu'elles
sont beaucoup plus attrayante c'est ce
qu'il dit un il dit voyez dans la page
d'accueil sous abonnez vous je n'avais
pas lu tout le même mot j'ai pris du
temps à voir à savoir où ça se trouvait
vous savez pas de comparer les balados
de hercé vous savez quand on fait
quelque chose une entrevue un reportage
ça soude fox s'est reproduit ce fond de
ballades au juste la balle abonnez vous
donnez-vous on va cliquer dessus pour
voir à quoi ça ressemble plus bas on est
quand même texte intel puis la caisse
convoyage épaule me lunettes je peux pas
voir marie-claude un apport à l'adoption
en violet au dessus je pose mon et
android oncle éclate subi on voit quoi
on voit assez il faut télécharger
quelque chose c'est ça sa première fois
je vois ce menu là c'est de nouveau
quand même cette nouvelle plateforme
comme ça et ça va très très bien
six parce que ça va exploser c'est par
catégorie donc on a les chroniques les
entrevues les émissions ça vaut vraiment
la peine d'aller voir si elle va faire
on va faire pousser les enquêtes pour la
semaine prochaine
d'accord on va voir s'il ya quelque
chose de dangereux dans ce nouveau
service qui est affaire de pots de vin
on joue ensemble à la devinette la vidéo
5 images vous propose cinq images les
gens qui nous regardent joue au même jeu
ils ne savent pas quel est le sujet des
missions et ensemble 5 images quelques
secondes à peine pour devenir le thème
vous crier dès que vous pensez être sur
la bonne piste on garde son ensemble
déclaré j 20 gr est ce qu'on est prêt
pour la vidéo cette image oui tu la vois
la première image le empress bateau
avant m
ouais tu as fait naufrage et bien des
années sans ça les bateaux de croisière
donc à leseur tourisme va écouter c'est
tout et tout est lié
moyens qu'il est tout à fait
environnementales les chercheurs hier
sur ce qui se passe dans saint-laurent
le sait laurent environ lui faisait la
piste oui pollution vous avez les
mots-clés continuer
égouts oui égouts ah ouais musée bon à
la baignade dans le saint-laurent
patates et quand même d'aniane à sanaa
où le fleuve saint laurent était le plus
pollué hockey et est-ce qu'on peut
encore s'y baigner excellente question
c'est une bonne question pour l'été ça
oui à certains moments a pas rendu à cet
endroit
certainement quand je dis pluie non dans
ce bar cosy des coliformes un certain
jean brousse est possible vous êtes tous
des saveurs vous nous menons des
baigneurs on va commencer dans quelques
instants qui va lui vous en dire plus là
dessus si vous le permettez vous
connaissez la tradition on met à
l'épreuve vos connaissances générales
qui sont très profonds grossir notre
effectif et renault est toujours le
meilleur
nous sommes alors là vraiment il va
falloir qu'on tente de l'abattre soyez
humbles raymond vous avez une mémoire
phénoménale est ce que votre mouvement
or voici première question on affiche à
l'écran la première question premier
tour il y avait foule à perdre
dans chaque émission il ya semboules à
perdre au maximum alors voici la
longueur du fleix serein et l'équivalent
de la distance existant entre quelle
ville là vous demandez bien sûr mais oui
mais qu'est ce que ce qu'on a le choix
de réponse oui dès que ça apparaît à
l'antenne
je vous donne le choix de réponses on
est ce qu'on est prêt pour le petit jeu
la première boule oui voilà à quoi
est-ce que là c'est la distance paris
rome la longueur du fleuve saint laurent
est ce que c b paris moscou est ce que
c'est c'est paris lisbonne où est ce que
ce serait c'est plutôt paris athènes la
longueur du fleuve saint-laurent est
l'équivalent de la distance existant
entre quelle ville j'ai mis ça dans la
géographie européenne parce que tout le
monde la connaît 1
moi j'hésite entre ben oui des mais bon
je vais je vais aller avec tahri moscou
mais peut-être que cette période est
trop grand paris moscou
moi je dirais séparer les balles paris
lisbonne lisbon c'est la capitale du
portugal
j étais cette vraie c'est pour ça que
j'ai choisi cette chose ce choix de
réponses et puis d est ce que quelqu'un
va choisir des éléments paris athènes
moi j'hésite un tatami moscou jeudi à
vouziers athènes grèce pas pu séparer
les points ou parce que moi aussi
j'avais mentionné que j'existais le
monstre d'annoncer un show de réponse
par par participa à la barre mais pense
malheureusement pour vous tous ça les
roms paris rome
le projet wii en 109 km par hiram et
puis la distance la longueur du prince
laurent 1190 1km semer la presse que le
golf est inclus là dedans
non nous on arrête le fleuve nous le
golf comme un style à écoutez moi je ne
suis pas un spécialiste je vais me
tourner vers le sud qui se trouve sur
sky on va voir si lui a cette réponse
floue que vous allez jarre poser des
questions à vous alors notre invité
aujourd'hui notre spécialiste qui nous
intéresse beaucoup à la question de la
pollution du fleuve saint laurent de la
qualité de l'eau c'est françois
guillemette professeur en sciences de
l'environnement à l'université du québec
à trois-rivières professeur bonjour
aujourd'hui on va situer trois rivières
pour ceux qui nous écoutent de
l'étranger s'est situé entre québec et
montréal
maintenant si toujours montréal pour les
gens qui nous est que de l'étranger
s'est situé entre trois rivières et
kingston c'est encore quelque 107 encore
la région du fleuve saint laurent mais
c'est quoi le fait seul où ça commence
où s'arrête elles sont principalement
seront plus viendra sans doute qui
commence de bris à la naissance sa
récente en essence dans la sortie en
ontario et va parcourir comme ça
la côte est américaine et canadienne
jusque dans les coins du québec et
ensuite on va tranquillement dans
l'estuaire traoré non blason mais cette
transition entre l'eau douce et l'eau
salée
il va passer un bon rhume ou ski tout
avoir tout de plus bas encore on va
rentrer dans le golfe saint laurent
on espérait grande ouverture qu'on voit
le sur la carte parce qu'on garde à vue
là quand québec
et vous quand vous enquêtez sur la
qualité de l'eau le long de ce grand
corridor fluvial vous enquêtez sur toute
la longueur ou sur une longueur en
particulier vous êtes le spécialiste je
pense québécois il y en a deux ou trois
mais je pourrais dire vous êtes un des
plus connus sur ces questions là depuis
quelques années vous faites des
recherches très poussées ou es ce que
vous avez accentuée vous mettez l'accent
présentement oui à l'extérieur on a un
agrès de la chaîne m6 et qui abrite deux
laboratoires à l'intérieur à la
particulier de l'abattoir sec
le sommet de lumière et l'on peut
traiter des échantillons d'eau par
exemple sur la nationale à venir dès
qu'on les écoles du club et dont on
semble pas que l'analyse là-dessus dont
on parlait de l'école font écho pour
l'avenir mon mesure aussi d'autres un
peu plus loin qu'on avoir libératoire
des équipes qui font partie de la
définition complète ressort ainsi au
québec et l abattoir ce qu'il autres
sections du v10 navy qui permettent par
exemple de prendre des mesures avec des
sondes sur les lumières de profondeur de
vitesse de courage
donc sans plus en laboratoire
informatique avec des gars pas quelque
chose de détecteurs oublier le petit
truc qui se passe dans l'environnement
et donc nous on patrouille
principalement la section entre les
grands lacs et québec et ensuite les
limites de diversité québec rimouski qui
elle offre de rachat
un père violent et eux vont patrouiller
par exemple dans l'histoire il donne
parce que leur batterie vous habitez à
face sur la navigation les grandes pas
bien démarré tout notre côté notre avis
il ya un espèce de des configurations
comme un catamaran
il nous permet en fait deux fois aller
dans les oeufs dans des eaux très
profondes jusqu'à un mètre de papon
seulement donc et ça nous donne beaucoup
à faire a fait mener notre île à cuincy
plus favorable qu'est ce qui se passe
sur les tributaires qui rendent un
fleuve sont allés dans les îles autour
de montréal et qui ont des petites
machines notamment du dollar en tant que
tel et voyez ici à derrière retour les
images on voit à l'écran les étudiants
que nos laboratoires humides dont on
traînait traiter des champions donc on
vient de recueillir et qui seront
ensuite le tout à l'heure mais qu'ils
mettent maryse j'avais je voulais vous
demander comment le fait que la glace
la formation glace dure moins longtemps
sur le fleuve à cause du réchauffement
climatique
comment ça affecte la pollution de l'eau
de bonnes questions
le buzz ce côté là j'ai pas un gramme
éléments de réponse à donner ce matin la
tension s'est pour l'instant on se rend
compte c'est que les allées les algues
bleu vert par exemple vont avoir des
blues beaucoup plus tôt dans la saison
donc on apprend que c'est la grille ont
dit non quand tu parles beaucoup
l'actuel donc avec quelques années bon
parce qu'on est comme ça sans qu'il y
ait à se détendre au québec qui plombent
aussi des problèmes toxiques pour les
organismes et des poissons même que
l'humain si on se donne par exemple et
donc les mains sont à lire cette
découverte glacial
donné je me permets à la lumière des
rentes est beaucoup plus tôt lot de très
choqué beaucoup plus tôt à la saison il
a par exemple on peut avoir des
pressions de cet état est le résidu
toxique et fédéral est en train on s'est
rendu compte aussi part au wrc qu' il ya
un immense lac flux bien en plein centre
du fleuve saint-laurent effet le lac
saint-pierre et qui contient qui abrite
en fait d'un paquet de des plantes
aquatiques de macrophytes qui servent
les lutteurs par exemple à différents
comme les poissons comme la personne est
tranquillement qui sont rencontre avec
avec la parole du mouvement est assez
important par le milieu agricole en
augmentation des défèrements et des
productions les sympathies fils en place
tranquillement c'est laid back office
donc on parle de la mi-temps qui comme
soit tape donc le poisson avec un et
vidéo qui est peut-être publie un détail
au risque d'aliéner faste pour la
comédie organise en faisant un peu de
recherche en préparation à notre
entrevue aujourd'hui j'ai vu beaucoup de
grands titres de journaux et des fois
des choses qui sont complètement aux
antipodes
vous avez ça va très bien du côté du
fleuve sonara les choses s'améliorent ou
encore ça va très mal vous sans utiliser
des mots trop compliqué ça va comment ça
se présente
ouais c'est un peu comme d'accord mais
pour ça il dames 1 la blague c'est le
seul incident qui avait pris un gros
coup
ou quelqu'un grosse brosse dernier à
mende en keirin clic est un peu
en termes québécois magané donc un peu
vos ressources qui vont bien de façon
moins bien et bref il ya encore beaucoup
d'espoir
lorsqu'on part le fait à l'heure avec
d'autres grands clubs dans le monde
on est quand même encore dans une bonne
position
par contre il ya des choses qui vont
moins bien influe sur tous nos
responsables par exemple de contaminants
émergents qui augure qui ont été moins
suivie d'un passé qu'on témoins sculptés
nouveau politique aussi au niveau des
dvd des lois ou de réduction aux tireurs
dont par exemple un élément qui est
assez important c'est une caisse qui
touche les travaux de mon collègue
sébastien un divertissement rien sur les
champs magnétiques sur les pesticides
sur les hormones sur les artifices et
qu'on rajoute dans l'eau donc c'est des
choses qui n'étaient pas nés sans
mesurer systématiquement la personne à
faire le party commence avec médecins en
partie grâce à vos travaux et ce genre
de choses là bon mais on connaît pas
encore tous les ponts savoir qu'elle
comptait épouser organismes mais c'est
sûr quand on est avec beaucoup de six
substances le maintenant dans l'eau est
bon il ya quand même pu essayer de
savoir respirer effectivement c'est
avoir un impact néfaste sur la faune
aquatique sur mon goût même parce que
bon pour savoir que la masse des
pressions québécois reprend son eau
potable directement du club donc il a
posé pour savoir est ce que maintenant
si sexy substances ne pas faire trop
dans l'eau potable ensuite mon question
que mon personnage est parent pas encore
beaucoup touché mais c'était le point
des recherches qui tue mais bon par
exemple si on parle des pesticides et
son inculture une chose qu'on a observé
c'est que on les retrouve on trouve
estime à environ l'ensemble de nos
chansons conneries quand ils ont des
grands lacs au québec
par contre il faut savoir c'est que dans
la majorité des cas on est vraiment sous
les normes de santé publique actuelle
donc vous inquiétez pas ce qu'on les
déteste mais de notre côté on y va on
droite en remettant un peu votre wallard
me sens à 100
parce que bon on y entendait chedid m
lorsque vous parlez de normes
est ce qu'on parle de normes canadiennes
d'ailleurs l'international
comment se comparent de normes
canadiennes et leurs hommes d'abel
avance sur nous il ya beaucoup
d'habitants qui ont demandé d'interdire
complètement invitation en europe et qui
sont encore permis chez nous donc moi
j'ai l'impression que dans les
prochaines années il voir une question
se pose de savoir quel point on doit
s'aligner sur les normes plus strictes
en matière par les flammes attisées en
écriture et en asie comme le maïs et le
soya qu'on aime ce travail est alors
nommé importante pour la population pour
le bétail comme l'industrie parce que
j'étais donc vous proposer question du
plateau savoir parce que bon ben
maintenant complicité on essaie de
tendre vers d'autres de substances
étaient un peu moins nocives et de voir
s'il ya moyen de télécharger que
quelques pratiques si un cri collection
donc c'est privé style j'ai pas encore
les données pour les antibiotiques mais
bon et pour savoir que beaucoup
d'antibiotiques qui circule présentement
dans l'eau dans leur vin qui ont acheté
par les eaux potables et usées et au
savoir c'est bon on peut se poser la
question maintenant à qui on ne s'est
pas disputé le qui circulent dans l'eau
est-ce qu'ils vont on peut commencer à
réfléchir à savoir est-ce qu'ils vont
favoriser l'émergence de super pathogène
résistant à 10,46 l'asthmatique donc on
pense m'en attendais pas du tout le
personnel de bactéries font très très
difficile à combattre
maintenant est-ce que le reflet des
antibiotiques non traitée comme ça dans
leur favoriser l'émergence pardon aussi
d'espèces invasives ça s'est passé par
catherine à l'époque les carpes
asiatiques qui ont quitté les bancs
l'eau des bassins fermés et qui ont
remonté le mississippi sud sont rendus
maintenant dans le lac érié
éventuellement éventuellement aussi
cette espèce invasive
se retrouveront naturellement dans le
saint laurent
est-ce qu'on voit venir la chose ouais
bon en fait marc manach travail sur le
sujet en ce moment et rapidement il ya
quelqu'un qui est de 306 me souviens
bien il ya une carpe et d'éthique et été
pêché par un pêcheur dans le samsara ici
albouy de montréal est bon c'est un
individu pour l'instant qu'on a réussi à
récolter
d'un côté donc s à l'autre côté des
collègues à l'inversé la banque qui ont
pu continuer la gardienne
environnementale pouvoir s
qu'effectivement on trouve des traces de
kapadia tic et c'était détecter un petit
peu partout à certains endroits d'un
personnage mais on n'a pas de
confirmation visuelle en choeur qui
correspond à ces signalements
l'environnement par contre on appelle
berthold espèce de retour aux quatre
cantons erika que pkp souris et quelques
années l'analyse est pas mon collègue
cette fois rien pour savoir un peu c'est
quoi son sont en déplacement nous sommes
solides évidence et laura est pour le
moment les données qu est-ce que
quelqu'un qui nous inquiète c'est que
bref et les gars sur le boulevard
saint-laurent syrie s'est pas promené
encore dans les tributaires
c'est quelqu'un d'une grande crainte que
savoir c'est vraiment un grand ami de
bière qui sont adjacents pour le moment
il semble qu'ils allaient voyager des
grands lacs lé dans la mesure où vient
donc la halle aux vivres aux mains des
grands lacs formés en majorité pour le
moment donc et c'est une donnée qu'on a
alors activé
yves le mans c'est dans les très
préoccupé par ça on essaie d'en capturer
d'autres un film on n'espérait pas
capturé avec une à vivre c'est pas
quelque part 2 impasse compte avoir à
vivre un migrant rachat du fond pour
capturer beaucoup de poissons et pour
l'instant ne pas capturer dans un
attentat terroriste un bon signe parce
que bon on vous dit on n'a pas encore
capturé dans d'autres on n'a pas vu
d'autres pistes mènent pour l'instant
mais notre côté on l'espère après un
4ème que doivent savoir que leurs
histoires de vie qu'est ce qu'on peut
savoir ici c'est que la cape qu'on a
capturé quelques captures et pardon
déposé cap le conte résultats sauter et
à sortir de l'eau mais plutôt qui est
une carpe
la papauté mais quand on va prendre un
maillot visuellement donc c'est un peu
petit mais aussi des traces de ce côté
là parce qu'on les voit pas visuellement
commencé à coter de narino forte en
approche
la crème bonheur c'est que ce type de
carte bleue prend pas la peine de vous
ou consomment une quantité astronomique
de macrophytes il sera ventilé la vie de
la personne
entre autres il deviendra chine à leurs
actionnaires qui relie de macrophytes on
peut donc pas seulement ce que la carte
de vos départements afin que cet endroit
là il commence à un débat au risque
d'oubli comme les vaches lancent à la
mairie comme moi j'ai beaucoup de
questions mais disons que je vais m'en
tenir à une au niveau de la baignade
surtout en milieu urbain les gens de
plus en plus essayer de se réapproprier
le fleuve est ce que vous encourager ce
vous qu'on se baigne de plus en plus
dans le fleuve skis et ski baignable le
fleuve à l'heure actuelle une bonne
question
ap dans mon laboratoire mental donc j'ai
beaucoup de temps avec les microbes
islah et la ronde à l'environnement et
dames en laboratoire on a mesuré les
comptes des colis de meilleurs
classiques comme toujours des fait
savoir ce qu'on ferme une plage on la
garde à la grande ampleur il ya quelques
années quelques éléments ici de
l'importance la première chose c'est que
le fleuve pour savoir si la chronologie
assez complexe la majorité mais reçoit
70 % des villes à québec provient des
grands lacs
donc le saint laurent à sa servante de
mérignac 1 1 naissance des grands lacs
qui coule directement donc on voit par
un thriller qui vient de confirmer le
manour une grosse rivière qui coule et
ensuite ajoute à ça ça fait donc deux
types de masse d'eau donc larry rustre
par exemple il ya quelques mois par 6%
de l'ebit total pas tout petit
tributaire qui sont qui draine des vélos
qui draine les milieux agricoles de la
vallée du saint laurent clément ajoute
des masses d'eau et c'est mal lotis que
ceux qui pour savoir ce qu'elle était un
mélange au bout ou très peu sur des
kilomètres et des kilomètres donc on
peut avoir des masses d'eau expert en
couleur de ses propriétés il parcourt
c'est laurent côte à côte pendant mes
clientes et déclamant pourquoi je pars
de stock c'est que lorsqu'on regarde les
colis mais qui sont donc ces deux là qui
nous indiquent la présence potentielle
de dire un pathogène donc au cerveau est
connu comme thème qui dangereuses pour
la santé humaine mais ces pathogènes qui
viennent avec donc souvent on parle
moins mais on met des normes se vanter
d'être malade et un rhume infection à la
gorge et erreurs week end donc lorsqu'on
mesure de police dans le pétrin un ebit
qu'on a on l'observé
après montréal à la sortie parce que bon
à montréal pour l'instant on ne dormirai
pas qu'il est un grand joueur mondial
est un moyen de sauver une comme tel on
a pour l'instant c'est même un cap en
primaire de des eaux usées ce qui veut
dire que on les décortique négoce
particules subli et le reste va
continuer son parcours dans le
saint-laurent ensuite d'en raccorder
votre vélo vaches donc levage les hommes
orient et pour l'instant le parcours le
traitement secondaire ou tertiaire dans
ce sens pour nous devons nous en ferons
club une place pour détruire les
batteries
le rationnement dangereuses ou comme aux
colis mais les pathogènes donc mais pas
c'est sûr que lorsqu'on passe un navire
le on a un graphique de coded qui
surprenait mais reste présent dans saint
laurent sur des clubs du big la main et
broussailles lot une fois première année
qu'on appelle là-bas même si en 2006
avec un avis fondé sur un pénis d'accès
y tient et on le mesure bien pic de cody
hay seulement 9e de sa vie de ces types
parce que bon ça vient de là que ma main
c'est hyper déconfite peuvent apporter
des colis qui vient des grandes villes
nîmes et keaton et on se lance comme à
fond est ce que cela nous mesurons coben
directement est terminée qu'elle a
effectivement une petite masse des
sections du bac est bien qui était
contenu par connie ya un recul a
tranquillement la mince tout en cédant
jusqu'à montréal montreal la pâte libère
ou appelez au liban où vous transporter
un colis de montréal jusqu'à trois plats
et qui passe par des leaders et
d'artisans qui connaissent peu de
shopping
elle passe alors à prendre ni taxes
indien et votre la masse d'eau baisse la
centrale qui avait des grands lacs
jusque là le contrôle via ce que l'on a
été primé l'an j'ai comparé le signal
fort mal de monde donc et cette action
le examen n'est pas une raison pour les
baigneurs il nous reste encore un
problème on espère que montréal quelques
années normales de mettre en place un
stand aux innovations dont lorsqu'on
aura ça ça m'a beaucoup aidé cette
problématique là on a observé mme cissé
qu'il y ait beaucoup tripple travail qui
gère les rênes des terres agricoles ou
débile qui amène une charge de connu à
l'intérieur du système
et là encore une fois du halal est drôle
et j complexe à l'image donc qui vient
d'un script alors est visible et colis
ou vraiment sur les rives de l'art bien
et l'a donc après ce sont seulement
l'ouest que les gens respectent belle
constance et sur les berges et anvers
gand d'accéder pour aller se baigner
donc les blanchons les plages mistral ou
en envoie projeté pour le futur best se
comptent sur les rives et donc on a on a
affaire à des conduites leur avis
comprenant systématique
malheureusement sont beaucoup dérive
d'un bâtiment de contrecoeur par exemple
qui est bordée par la masse d'eau
pertinemment ça va c'est bien parce
qu'il revienne il n'y avait pas de
connaissance est très élevé dès qu'on
n'était presque pas et c'est parti cette
france mais aussi les remettre votre et
bien en amont de montréal qu'est-ce qui
est percé encore une fois par les
ovaires la paix devrait parce qu'il ya
une couleur ou berthier dire des grands
lacs où ils sont très très proches mais
dès qu'on arrive plupart par ces mots
rien avec kiev ont été longues et laval
montréal la cgt ça risque il ya des
arrêts importants des codie processeur
va falloir absolument informer les
bureaux de tourisme
quitte à des avis importe ensuite à vous
à vos recherches je vous remercie
infiniment nous avoir donné cette image
multi dimensionnelle ou et
multidimensionnel de ce qui se passe
dans notre société
présentement je vais passer un bon été
et je sais que c'est la période chaude
pour vous au niveau des recherches
cela vous met bout à bout ça vous fait
quoi
c'est françois qui met professeur en
sciences de l'environnement a lyon c'est
du québec à trois rivières
nous sommes prêts pour le deuxième tour
de la grosse boule 30 bout la perte vous
avez déjà perdu tous 20 boules que ça se
produit voici on vous présente cette
question toujours sous forme de petits
graphiques pour vous aider à suivre ce
qui se passe à l'émission en beauté
voici d'abord un petit préambule il ya
près d'un milliard d'années
qu'est-ce qui se trouvait en lieu et
place sur le site actuel de la vallée du
fleuve saint-laurent on n'était pas là
vous n'étiez pas là donc 1000 milles
millions 1000 1100 millions d'années
d'un grand amour est exact est-ce que ce
qui se trouvait ici c'était un vaste
océan d'une profondeur rivalisant celle
de l'océan pacifique où est-ce que
c'était bon un gigantesque cratère
creusé par l'écrasement d'une météo
météo et ferreuse ou est-ce que c'était
c'est un plateau d'une élévation
semblable à celui du tibet actuel alors
vaste océan gigantesque cratère où
plateau très élevé comparable au tibet
qui répond vous
tous d'accord vaste océan maryse je vais
aller avec la même réponse mais là si on
coule on coule tout ça et vous couler
tous en soit voici la bonne réponse
c'est non c'est pas baissé cessé mes
moyens
ben oui c'était un gigantesque comme on
appelle ça un continent qui se trouvait
ici là il ya une oppression milliards
ouais plus d'un milliard d'années pas
dix mille ans il ya dix là c'était la
mer de champlain
voilà mais avant cela un milliard
d'années c'était il y avait ce soutien
continent et autour de ce super
continent très élevé en certaines
parties il y avait un océan très profond
bien peut-être eu des cratères creusés
par des météorites je n'étais pas là
pour vous dire vrai les idées on parle
de 22000 pour le k2 donc ce qui peut
peut-être moins que ça on parle d'un
plateau le plateau tibétain qui est un
peu plus ou un peu moins élevé que karl
babin d'accord de on en apprend des
choses 0 pour chaque enfant n'est pas
très bon jusqu'à m donc vous n'avez pas
faim et puis ceux que nous aidons aussi
peuvent apprendre grâce au défi de la
régie le deuxième défi que représente
cette semaine on va aller sur le web on
est prêt pour le défi me dit on avec
grand plaisir bien sûr
alors voici au sujet de ce défi on
ajoute toujours à la suite de notre
entretien sur facebook ou sur youtube
qu'on retrouve sur notre page de tintin
canada chaque émission d'hier un
reportage qui pousse à rattacher un peu
comme des chaloupes derrière le titanic
et vous apprenez davantage cela je vais
vous montrer ces images ce qu on a
appelé ça le dossier x x c'est pas parce
qu'il ya quelque chose ville à 10 face
l'espace des choses importantes qui
changerait le nom est ce qu'on est
préfet c'est déjà arrivé que vous
vouliez faire tous nos internautes
peuvent composer l'adresse de rci
net.com vie de xx x ils vont trouver ça
non ça c'est juste pour mettre une
fausse piste voilà alors en effet l'on
est là il est question
moi des choses qui ont tous lu au monde
maritime et des océans quoi et se sent
donc à découvrir cette semaine sur xxx
ça vient on passe à autre chose
troisième jeu la grosse boule j'ai perdu
50 brûle tous et chacun sur les cent
cette semaine on risque d'être en pointe
pour la deuxième mauvaise mais ça
s'aggrave encore peut-être finir à 0 1
ça serait plutôt sereine première de loi
une première pour ce mode de saison je
vous dis que c'est pas fort 0 à l'examen
ça serait pas beau alors voici troisième
tour de l'atmosphère un peu mieux fait
oui et vous aviez savuth ils seront 20
août 1 alors voici à partir de quelle
taille je vous pose la question on la
montre à l'antenne également dès qu'on a
la chance de presser sur le bouton
numéro 38 à partir de quelle taille aux
navires doit-il être conduit par un
pilote local qui a reçu son diplôme pour
avancer sur le fleuve saint laurent
parce que le vin se levant et très
mouvementée en certaines sections vous
le savez il ya des rapides et des
exclusives et c'est pas des excuses les
exclus et les moins profond à certains
endroits donc il faut connaître les
endroits où c'est plus profond qui les
découvrira dès qu'ils vont avoir des
directions différentes
alors voici est ce que c'est à partir de
15 mètres que comme capitaine vous devez
dire on a besoin de quelqu'un à bord
pour piloter
est ce que ces bébés à partir de 30
mètres ça c'est 100 pieds pour ceux qui
veulent avoir une référence au québec
ou est ce que c'est c'est 50 mètres à
partir de quel moment légalement vous
êtes tenu de vous arrêter comme
commandant de bord et dire j'ai besoin
de l'aide d'un pilote local alors
marie-claude moi j'irai à à partir de 15
mètres donc à peu près 45 pieds de
quatre experts avec 15 m à bourbon et
marie claude reymond qui sait où b b
pour jouer chez tous les cas c'est beau
mais là moi j'hésite clos de raymond je
pense je vais aller avec bea d'agrément
vraiment c'est plus ceux plus fiables
c'est plus fiable
non m eh bien vous auriez tous raison
mais malheureusement il n'ya qu'un
gagnant aujourd'hui c'est y en a deux
mehdi b vous avez dit bébel et c'est
presque les 5 étoiles le prouve c'est la
bonne réponse
j'ai zéro vous avez écouté
surtout lorsque je vais vous proposer
c'est toujours une tradition l'émission
on finit toujours pas d'image de la
semaine le jouer a ajouté m nota bene
mois pour moi l'image la semaine c'est
cet horrible accident sur la 440
l'autoroute qui se trouve au nord de
montréal à laval
neuf véhicules automobiles de camions
quatre membres des histoires dans les
journaux des témoignages et en banque
jeter c'est horrible c'est horrible
parce que moi je passe ma vie sur la
route évidemment ce donc je me sens
interpellé mais je me dis pour ceux qui
ne sont pas ici à montréal ou québec
cette semaine qu'elle était donc cette
image que vous pouvez être images la
semaine alors voici petite musique de
plein de tension est ce que c'était les
suspects recherchés le fameux manoir en
suisse arrêté un très très bonnes
discussions et historien mais non est-ce
que c'est nord américain c'est noir
américain fait que ces canadiens
c'est maintenant canadien
malheureusement belgique au sujet du
vélo ces canadiens pour pas donner son
opinion
allez-y continuer question je réponds
quand on est au québec maintenant avec
sa politique l'éthique à ça c'est une
bonne histoire les laiteries qui apporte
la maladie de lyme
mais c'est pas ça ça aurait pu être un
autre bon choix éditorial quelle est
l'image la semaine outre un disque ça en
tout cas ça avance avance sur patins sur
des roues ça avance sur des roues au hcc
la trottinette électrique on voit la
prestation vous gagnez laissant bull que
vous aviez perdu peut-être ajouter sa
démission comme rigueur oui c'est vrai
on peut se rattraper
avez-vous déjà croisé les trottinettes
électriques en tant que cycliste
pathak cycliste laroquais j'ai essayé
d'en louer qu'acheter un petit
réajustement mai mais j'ai vu passer un
reportage apparemment que les
trottinettes électriques sont plus
polluantes que prendre l'autobus puisque
n auraient une vie riddick de quelques
jours c'est pourquoi il ya les forces
industrielles qui tendent eux de faire
en sorte que tout ce qui est électrique
et mal interprété mal acceptée par les
consommateurs parce que le grand bond il
n'y a pas de conspiration assumer que je
sens que c'est un peu comme la cigarette
sur la belle époque folle lascars assez
bons plats santé elles mêmes et métiers
c'est une publicité sans fin de la
guerre et fatigante mais on allume
cigares et cigarettes camel recommandé
par les médecins locaux
alors écoutez là c'est soir de transfert
qui arrivent à montréal après être passé
par calgary cadel casque obligatoire
puisqu'il surprenant c'est que les
cyclistes ne sont pas obligées de porter
des casques alors là je me demande à
l'administration plainte
un petit peu à voir du problème et
l'exit l'administration plainte mais je
parle de notre mère récemment valérie
plus intense qui portent le casque bonne
décision inimaginable de printemps j'ai
déjà été un portier est une fois et j'ai
béni mon casque mais cros non mais bon
qu'est ouais ça va être beau à voir
parce que à calgary j'ai entendu un
reportage viennent de ce même jour
depuis laquelle jouer mais il ya
beaucoup de risques d'accident beaucoup
de factures dit-on dans les urgences des
six allait bien les casques obligatoires
a alors le cette année c'est jusque
débit gervis peu après ils vont voir ce
qu'ils vont faire pareil que la
municipalité m'oriente pourrait faire
beaucoup d'argent avec ça parce qu'elles
vont à la licence d'exploitation à
l'entreprise ou menu une blague line
abeau le principe à la maladie de lyme
donc vous parlions celle qu'on peut y
aime lines et y est la même un peu tiqué
sur ma chose mais comme bois reymond des
marteaux marie-jo bain marie claude
simard merci pour la semaine prochaine
merci obama
[Musique]